[Music]
visually the idea of integration is very
intuitive to find the area we divide the
region into small strips then we
approximate the area of a strip with a
rectangle like this then we patch the
area of all these rectangles to get the
approximate area under this curve now as
we increase the number of strips our
approximation gets better and better and
in the limit the width of the strip's
tends to zero the approximate area
approaches the area under the curve this
is the idea of integration that we've
seen so far to find the area we break it
into smaller parts and then add the
areas of the small parts to get the area
of the whole but does this idea actually
work in this video we will see how to
exactly apply this idea to find the area
under the graph or curve of a function
consider this functions let's say we
want to find the area under the graph
between X equal to 2 and 6 can you tell
me what is the shape it's a trapezoid
even without integration we know how to
find its area it's equal to the half of
its altitude times the sum of its bases
here the base of this trapezoid will be
these two lines and its altitude will be
this line solving this will give us the
area of the trapezoid as 16 but how can
we use integration to find this area
will we get the same answer let's see
that in the next part of the lesson
how do you think we can find this area
using integration what is the first
thing we should do correct
we divide this interval into n equal sub
intervals let's denote these sub
intervals like this now notice that the
width of this interval is 6 minus 2
that's 4 so the width of any sub
interval will be equal to 4 over N let's
denote it by Delta X this enables us to
measure these sub intervals in terms of
Delta X this means X naught is equal to
2 X 1 is equal to 2 plus Delta X X 2
will be 2 plus 2 times Delta X and so on
in the end 6 which is equal to X n will
be equal to 2 plus n times Delta X now
what should we do next
in each sub interval we find the
approximate area under the graph using
rectangles but now observe any one sub
interval we can draw many rectangles
here depending on the height we take so
which rectangle should we choose
notice that the rectangles which cross
the graph will have areas closer to the
area under the graph so we should take
any rectangle whose height is equal to
the value of y corresponding to a point
on the graph for simplicity let's take
the minimum Y value in each sub interval
as the height of the respective
rectangles we can see that in each sub
interval the value of y corresponding to
the left-hand value of x will be the
minimum Y value so in the first sub
interval the minimum Y value will be
equal to f of 2 in the second it will be
F of 2 plus Delta X and so on
and in the end interval it will be F of
2 plus n minus 1 times Delta X now we
draw the rectangles choosing these as
the heights base of each rectangle has
width equal to Delta X so the sum of the
areas of these rectangles will be equal
to this on putting the values of the
function we will get this now if we
simplify it we will get this expression
notice that the series here in the
bracket is an arithmetic progression we
note that the sum of an arithmetic
progression series is equal to this here
n is the number of terms in this series
we have n minus 1 terms so we will get
the sum of this series to be n times n
minus 1 over 2 so the sum of the areas
of these rectangles will be equal to
this we see that the sum of the areas of
these rectangles depends on the number
of the sub intervals and and the width
of the sub intervals Delta X but we know
according to this relation that as we
increase the number of sub intervals
their width decreases so let's
substitute Delta X as 4 over n here
simplifying it will give us this what
should we do next let's observe one
particular sub interval if we divide the
sub interval further into two parts and
draw the rectangle considering the
minimum Y value in each we see that the
sum of these areas will be closer to the
area under the graph than this area so
this means that to get a better
approximation we have to increase the
number of sub intervals notice that the
sum of the area of rectangles now only
depends on the number of intervals n so
if we increase the number of intervals
the value of the term 8 over n will
decrease this means that in the
limit n tends to infinity this term 8
over N will approach 0 so the sum of the
areas of rectangles will approach the
number 16 this is the area under the
graph we found out earlier so we see
that in the limit n tends to infinity
the area of these rectangles approaches
the area under the graph here in each
sub-interval we took the minimum y-value
in this case we can see that the sum of
the areas of the rectangles will always
be less than the area under the graph so
this sum of the areas of the rectangles
is called the lower sum for this reason
we denote the sum by putting a lower bar
but now what if instead of the minimum Y
value in each sub-interval we had taken
any other Y value will that also work
what do you think let's continue this in
the next part
[Music]
you